Nadia wants to create a confidence
interval to estimate the mean driving
range for her company's new electric
vehicle she wants the margin of error to
be no more than 10 kilometers at a 90
percent level of confidence a pilot
study suggests that the driving range is
for this type of vehicle have a standard
deviation of 15 kilometers which of
these is the smallest approximate sample
size required to obtain the desired
margin of error so pause this video and
see if you can think about this on your
own so the traditional way that we would
construct a margin of error and a
confidence interval we take a sample and
from that sample we construct the mean
and then we add or subtract a margin of
error around that to construct the
confidence interval and the way that
we've done that since we're dealing with
means is we say alright if we don't know
the standard deviation of the population
it's appropriate to use the t statistic
so our critical value we'd to notice T
star and you'd multiply that times the
sample standard deviation divided by the
square root of your sample size now this
question is all about what is an
appropriate sample size given that we
want to have a 90% level of confidence
and what's tricky here is when you're
using a t-table right over here not only
do you need to know the 90% level of
confidence you also need to know the
degrees of freedom and the degrees of
freedom is going to be n minus 1 but we
don't know what that's going to be
without knowing n so how would we
determine an N similarly you don't know
what your sample standard deviation is
going to be until you actually take some
samples so instead of that well we could
think about we know that another
legitimate way to construct a confidence
interval and the margin of error is to
say alright I can take my sample mean
and I can add or subtract a z-score a
critical value and this time use the Z
table where if I multiply that times the
true population standard
deviation and divide that by the square
root of n now you might say well I don't
know the true population standard
deviation but they tell us a pilot study
suggests that the driving range is for
this type of vehicle have a standard
deviation of 15 kilometers so we could
use this as an estimate of our true
population standard deviation so this is
15 kilometers right over here and then
the good thing about a Z table is you
don't have to think about degrees of
freedom you could just look up your
confidence interval and so then we could
just say that look Z star times 15
kilometers over our square root of n
this right over here is our margin of
error this right over here is our margin
of error that has to be no more than 10
kilometers so that has to be less than
or equal to 10 and we can figure out
what the Z star needs to be for a 90%
confidence level and so then we just
solve for n so let's do that now to
figure out Z star I could use the Z
table but just for a diversity of
methodology let's use a a calculator
here so to figure out the Z value that
would give us a 90% confidence interval
I can use a function called inverse norm
and you can see that right over here
that's choice 3 let me just select that
and what it'll do is you give it the
area that you want under a normal curve
you can even specify the mean and the
standard deviation although you want the
mean to be zero and the standard
deviation to be 1 if you really want to
fight figure out a z-score here and so
what it'll do is it will give you the
z-score that will give you that
corresponding area and so I want and
actually it's already selected that I
want the center area to be 90% so I
could say 0.9 right over here if I use
the left tail then that means if I have
90% of the center that means I would
have 5% it either tails instead of doing
it 0.9 and center I could have done Oh
point O 5 and used the left tail or used
0.05 and use the right tail but this is
exactly what I want so let me just go
and paste this and so this should give
me the appropriate z value
so there you go if I want this middle
90% the center 90% I have to go one
point roughly one point six four five
standard deviations below the mean and
that same amount above the mean so it's
roughly our critical value here is
approximately one point six let's just
say one point six four five so we have
one point six four five times times
fifteen over the square root of n it's
going to be less than or equal to ten
and so now there's a couple of ways that
you could do this we could do a little
bit of algebra to simplify this
inequality I encourage you to do so or
you could even try out some values here
and see which of these ends would make
this true and we want the smallest
possible one I'll do it the algebraic
way because if you're actually doing
this in the real world now they would
not have a multiple choice right over
here she'd have to figure out the sample
size in order to conduct your study so
let's do that
so let's see if I divide both sides by
one point six four five and 15
what do I get I get one over the square
root of n is less than or equal to 10
over one point six four five over over
fifteen and then if I take the
reciprocal of both sides I get the
square root of n is greater than or
equal to from taking the reciprocal of
both sides and so this is going to be
one point six four five times 15 times
15 all of that over ten all of that over
ten see fifteen over ten is just one
point five so let me just write that as
one point five right over here and then
if I square both sides I would get that
n needs to be greater than or equal to
one point six four five x times one
point five and then all of that squared
I just squared both sides all of that
squared and so let's get our calculator
back we are going to have one point
six four five times 1.5 and then we want
to square it and we get six point
approximately six point zero six point
zero nine so n has to be greater than or
equal to six point zero nine and of
course our sample size needs to actually
be a whole number so what's the smallest
whole number that is larger than six
point zero nine well that's going to be
seven so that would be this choice right
over here this is the smallest
approximate sample size required to
obtain the desired margin of error and
of course we won't really really know
until we actually conducted the study we
obviously here use an estimate of the
population standard deviation we used
and we used a Z table but it will be
interesting when not the actually
conducts the study to see if our margin
of error is indeed no more than ten
kilometers with a ninety percent level
of confidence